car à vous lire ce sont pas simplement
les anglicismes qui pose problème c'est
sur le fond un management qui a oublié
le courage et l'autorité écrivez-vous au
profit ce sont mes terres mais c'est
pour résumer le au profit du ludique et
du de l'égalitarisme
vous avez donc co écrit ce livre avec
julia de funès il s'intitule la comédie
inhumaine on en a publié de larges
extraits ce matin dans le figaro
alors par exemple un extrait qu'on va
voir à l'écran enfin on envoie plusieurs
jeux je parle je cite le premier alors
que les salariés auraient besoin de sens
et d'autonomie on leur demande
instamment d'être heureux au travail
commentaires déjà pour lancer ce sujet
mais il ya un véritable problème dans
l'entreprise on le voit dans cette
rentrée ce qui déprime les gens ce n'est
pas d'aller travailler les gens aiment
bien travaillé c'est pas d'aller dans
leur entreprise
les gens aiment leur entreprise est de
plus en plus il aime l'entreprise en
règle générale ce qui ne supportent plus
ce sont les absurdités du management le
fait que l'entreprise soit un lieu qui a
importé toutes les théories managériale
bidon à la mode donc le bonheur au
travail les baby-foot les cours de yoga
et cetera les séminaires où on saute en
parachute
les gens n'en peuvent plus et c'est moi
le libère avec ce qu'il ya de finesse
qu'on a essayé de faire c'est une
critique libéral du management parce que
les gauchistes ont déjà fait 20 fois
donc c'est pas la maison ce qui est
drôle c'est si nous les libéraux qui
aimons l'entreprise
nous procédons à cette critique
exigeante ont reproché de vouloir un
retour à l'entreprise de grand papa avec
j'ai bien dans son bureau on bosse dans
son coin et un chef
non c'est pas ça on pense que les
salariés ont besoin d'autonomie et ça
c'est une grande différence avec le
management du xxème siècle qui était un
agent tech énormément de process écoutez
bien ça la complexité de l'environnement
économique depuis 1955 a été multipliée
par six la complexité de l'organisation
des entreprises dans le même temps a été
multipliée par 35
c'est dingue l'entreprise est devenue le
lieu de la bureaucratie et donc les
salariés passent leur temps en réunion
lille on n'en peuvent plus des réunions
même dans une entreprise aussi
extraordinaire que le figaro je suis sûr
que de temps en temps il ya une fille à
une réunion qui n'était pas tout à fait
utile ou qui est un peu longue
les gens n'en peuvent plus ils n'en
peuvent plus des réunions
ils n'en peuvent plus des powerpoint qui
ne servent à rien ils n'en peuvent plus
des managers où ils ont tant rire
ils n'en peuvent plus des managers qui
devrait lever les contraintes et qui en
met
et c'est vrai que là on n'est pas
démagogique on pense qu il faut un
retour de l'autorité du charisme mais il
faut laisser de l'autonomie notre
conseil aux entreprises
c'est si vous laissiez travailler vos
salariés laissez les travailler
philippe meyer l'autorité ce n'est pas
les galons sur la manche
l'autorité c'est ce qu'on acquiert quand
on a montré qu'on avait soi même une
compétence au moins égale à celle de
celui à qui on demande de remplir une
tâche
effectivement si c'est cette autorité là
qui revient tant mieux ça remplacera
très avantageusement ce que vous venez
de décrire qui et l'infantilisation
l'infantilisation l'infantilisation or
mais comme dans les comédies de molière
d'un nouveau langage alors qui est prêt
à l'anglais qui ne veut
quelquefois rien dire du tout et que
d'autres fois veut dire exactement la
même chose que ce qu'on dit en français
benchmarking
ça veut dire comparaison vous croyez que
quand on a dit la comparaison on a
dévalué la tâche qu'on est en train de
s'accomplir
c'est absurde or cette espèce de sabir
ridicule qui est devenu le patoine la
nouvelle bourgeoisie et dans le monde
des médias et la communication seigneur
jésus dieu sait que cette nouvelle
bourgeoisie est vraiment présente jusqu
à ce qu on n'en puisse plus les open
space on vous parlait aussi
moi je suis pour que le patron soit dans
son bureau la porte fermée qui jouent
aux solitaires et pendant ce temps là on
pourra tranquillement travailler mais
tout ça est une infantilisation qui
n'est pas du tout propre au monde de
l'entreprise
elle est haussier du monde de la culture
monde de la culture il ya moi ce qui m'a
frappé dans l'expectative est la parole
à nos nouvelles et éthiques
sur ce manège a traduit aussi la
difficulté à prendre des décisions
aujourd'hui finalement proyas temps de
réunion les réunions ça une fonction
pour se rassurer on pense que
collectivement on va trouver les
solutions qu'on est incapable de trouver
individuellement
moi je pense qu'il ya aussi quelque part
ou crainte du risque aujourd'hui qu'ils
existent et
diriger c'est décidé donc quand vous
décidez vous prenez des risques et le
management c'est une espèce d'idéologie
confortable avec des process à n'en plus
finir qui en effet infantilise les
salariés mais qui permettent de se
rassurer de se dire que finalement on va
prendre une décision en ayant l'aval de
ses salariés ou en tout cas de ses
subordonnés
donc je crois qu'il ya aussi cela
derrière l'idéologie du mal à essayer
autre chose c'est le trillion de la
société technicien moi j'engage tout le
monde
à relire jacques ellul parce que ce qu'a
dit jacques élu il ya 40 ans dans la
société technicienne sur le système
technicien sait ce que c'est ce que l'on
vit au millimètre près le management
c'est une forme de techniques de
techniques des relations humaines qui
déshumanise qui désenchante qui empêche
la spontanéité vous avez parlé des power
pente en effet aller dans ces séminaires
de cartes vous avez des cadres qui n'ont
plus du tout aucune éloquence mais qui
ne font que répéter relire les propos
sur qui sont qui sont sur leur sur leur
sur l'ours lie pardonnez-moi
l'anglicisme donc c'est à peu près ça
je trouve que votre critique est
parfaitement salutaire bravo et bien
apparemment vous avez dû également sur
twitter large part de nos internautes
qui sont d'accord avec vous le
management moderne et inefficace on a
posé la question tout simplement 66 % de
nos internautes répondent que oui il est
inefficace
marc landré vous n'avez pas parlé des
règles tout à fait utile du figaro selon
qui un petit bémol au rôle de alors
dites nous pourquoi le management
moderne et est au contraire tout à fait
profitable je sais pas ce que c'est que
le management moderne où le vieux le
management à la papa je pense que moi je
suis manager j'ai une équipe de 8
personnes j'essaye de la manager au
mieux je les affronte ils disent parfois
c'est vrai jeu léger de l'autorité et g
je viens de la base donc et je pense que
mon autorité et ma compétence est
reconnue par mon équipe je pense à leur
bien-être
je pense par exemple que lorsqu'il ya
des papiers à faire le soir et que parce
qu'il actuel qui tombe bien si je peux
la faire à leur place je la fais plutôt
que alors qu'ils sont pas bons ils sont
pas mobilisés ils sont mobilisables pour
ça mais si je peux me substituer à eux
je le fais je pense que ce qui ce qui
change peut-être c'est l'âge du
capitaine
c'est très difficile de ne pas ternir de
materner ses salariés ou ses
collaborateurs quand on est plus jeune
voir qu'on a le même âge que peut-être
que l'évolution du management de demain
c'est lorsqu'on conflit continuera à
confier des responsabilités à des gens
sur la base de leurs compétences quelles
que soient leur âge et à ce moment-là
l'infantilisation de gens plus âgés que
soit va devenir beaucoup plus compliquée
que ce qu'elle ne l'était dans la
société d'avant de ce qu'elle peut
encore l'être aujourd'hui et avec
l'irruption de l'intelligence
artificielle des nouvelles technologies
avec cette fameuse génération y z qui
demande de l'autonomie qui demande
effectivement qu'on lui lâche la grappe
qui demande qu'il n'y ait plus qui est
de la transversalité qui est des
management par projet je pense que ce
malade vente à la papa petit à petit je
veux dire pourra disparaître après on
fera pas du passé table rase on
n'arrivera pas dans une société où tout
le monde il est beau tout le monde il
est gentil al ajial bien sûr que non
mais peut-être que l'évolution de la
société fera qu' on ira vers un
management plus responsable
comme celui que vous appelez de vos
voeux alors joséphine juste qu'elle je
vous donne ma part
joséphine toujours qui est très présente
aujourd'hui nous dit oui à un management
basé sur l'humanité la valorisation de
l'individu
un jeune qui dit j'ai vécu en angleterre
et je peux vous dire que ce problème est
bien français pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion de comparer un peu les les
autres je suis pas convaincu par je
pense que dans les pays anglo saxons
contraire c'est beaucoup de de
verticalité je pense qu'il ya des pays
qui s'en sortent mieux comme les pays
scandinaves parce que plus généralement
leur contrat social est basé sur la
confiance et donc on retrouve ça à
l'intérieur des entreprises
je peux vous dire que les compagnies
d'assurance ou les banques américaines
c'est pire que les entreprises
françaises et marie cécile qui pose une
question très intéressante est
effectivement vous en parlez aussi c'est
le télétravail en plein essor ne donne
qu il pas justement plus d'autonomie aux
salariés vous vous êtes l'avocat du
télétravail absolument alors pas le
télétravail à 100% ce serait absurde
mais le télétravail
il oblige à la confiance à partir du
moment où vous séparer le management et
les salariés bla du coup vous êtes
obligé de vous faire confiance tout
simplement et donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très sain et les études
montrent que les gens travaillent plus
quand ils sont chez eux ou au bureau
ça pose une question quand même qui est
incroyablement profonde savez pourquoi
j'ai fait ce livre parce que un jour je
pourrai que c'est vrai à la fin d'une de
mes confuses une jeune femme elle vient
me voir elle me dit vivement ce week end
que j'ai enfin le temps de travailler
parce qu' elle ne pouvait même pas
travailler la semaine dans sa boîte
tellement elle était elle était harcelée
je suis très sensible à ce qu'a dit
philippe meyer / l'infantilisation je
pense qu'au fond l'entreprise
aujourd'hui est perméable à de grandes
évolutions de nos sociétés qui sont
d'une part l'infantilisation est
d'ailleurs dans les entreprises voyaient
dans les bureaux il ya de plus en plus
de bonbons des crocodiles haribo des
choses comme ça vous avez une salle de
réunion ça s'appelle la chocolaterie
l'autre ça s'appelle le bac à sable
donc vous avez ce phénomène
d'infantilisation et puis ce que vous
disiez à fort juste titre qui est quand
même étonnant quand on y pense c'est que
l'entreprise qui devrait le lieu du
risque le lieu de l'innovation tient
toujours ce discours mais bien souvent
elle ne l'est pas on dit aux salariés
innover mais attention mais les process
vous verrez pas d'innover soyez autonome
mais en réalité les réunions et
l'organisation fait que vous ne pouvez
pas être autonome
que pensez vous par exemple des congés
quelques entreprises qui disent moi je
ne gère pas les congés c'est chacun
prendre ce qui lui plaît c'est pousser
le bouchon un peu loin
oui c'est peut-être un peu jusqu'au
boutisme nez je suis pas je suis pas un
révolutionnaire
je suis plus sage que ça je pense que là
aussi vous avez dit quelque chose tout à
l'air qui m'a beaucoup frappée je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ça vous avez
dit au fond il faut que le patro le
patron soit dans son bureau et qui
laisse les salariés travailler mais moi
je fais plein de vous jeudi au patron sa
charte et aller ailleurs
2 - le président du medef local de la
cpm il ya beaucoup de mandat passionnant
france vous pourrez continuer de diriger
vous dirigerez parce que l'autorité dont
par les marques tout à l'heure elle
existe toujours
le charisme existe toujours mais ne
soyez pas sur le dos de leurs salariés
et lamont et moins démago qu'on pourrait
en avoir l'air c'est qu'on dit aussi si
vous avez des salariés dont le
comportement est suffisamment
problématique pour que vous n'ayez pas
confiance en eux je crois qu'il faut
penser à se séparer d'eric tout
simplement
mais dans les extraits que j'ai lu dans
le figaro de ce matin
vous parlez du management comme la
tyrannie moderne et vous en appelez à la
restauration de l'autorité entendu comme
nous venons les uns les autres de la
redéfinir mais d'abord je pense que
c'est très important mais ensuite je
suis quand même frappé par l'expansion
des modes de tyrannie il ya cette
tyrannie managériale cette tyrannie
sucre et de tout le monde doit être
gentil tout le monde
la tyrannie au contraire des réseaux
sociaux qui est une tyrannie de gens qu
de juges qui sont tellement pressée de
devenir bourreau que il se précipite de
pour remanier eux mêmes la guillotine
il ya quelque chose qui dans une société
où on s'estime beaucoup plus libre que
dans les moments dans les périodes
précédentes je pense qu'on a tort je
peux dire un mot c'est un peu à côté
mais sur le télétravail je pense aussi
que c'est très important mais je pense
que le télétravail ne pourra trouver
toute sa place que s'il ya des
politiques publiques d'aménagement du
territoire
ça veut dire des politiques publiques
qui favorise la sûreté et la régularité
des transports aériens et ferroviaires
et des politiques publiques qui assurent
la sécurité de la transmission par
internet je passe une partie de mon
temps pour deux ans que je suis
président du festival de théâtre de rue
d'aurillac dans le massif central je
dire si on comptait le nombre d'avions
annulée si on comptait le nombre de
jours pendant lesquels orange qui est le
seul diffuseur dans cette région là est
incapable d'assurer son service et on ne
peut pas encourager qui que ce soit à
venir travailler à distance dans ces
conditions marc landry ou quelqu'un
d'autre
ç'avait été un des chantiers du lancé
par gouvernement la meilleure couverture
4g
non mais le 4g plus ça c'est bientôt la
5g non mais sa femme est il à la fin des
soldes blancheporte tout ça ça va on en
est commandé que je crois qu emmanuel me
suis pas spécialiste du sujet humain et
le maquereau emmanuel macron à anticiper
la couverture de l'ensemble du
territoire avec la suppression des zones
blanches était prévue pour 2022
il ya des investissements
supplémentaires pour 2020 mais c'est sûr
des redéploiements de crédits qui
existait déjà avant et au final on se
retrouve avec le même package qu'avant
en revanche sur le télétravail
il ya une obligation maintenant qui dans
la loi qui est passé avec les
ordonnances de la loi travail où chaque
entreprise doit négocier maintenant un
plan de mise en oeuvre du télétravail
pour ses salariés
et il ne sera plus autorisée de refuser
un salarié de faire du télétravail à
partir du moment où l'accord aura été
signé un accord majoritaire entre ville
et ça c'est une vraie avancée importante
moi je t'ai autorise les journalistes à
faire du télétravail
le principal c'est que c'est que le
papier soit de qualité
peu importe qu'il était produit au
journal ou que chez soi et avec les
moyens modernes de communication
on est capable de rentrer d'être en
contact les uns avec les autres
même si on est physiquement séparés par
quelques kilomètres
non je voudrais demander ce qu a dit
philippe meyer le mot aménagement du
territoire
c'est un mot qui est complètement
disparu du lexique politique est ce
qu'il ya un ministère de l'aménagement
du territoire et du tout mais la menace
la notion même d'aménagement du
territoire elle ne passe pas que par le
réseau et ne passera que par leur aise
que par le numérique que par internet
elle passe aussi par de l'humain ça
c'est absolument capital vous avez parlé
d'aurillac et détail zone dans le sud
ouest aujourd'hui où vous avez des
services publics qui disparaissent la
vérité aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez
quand même fondamentalement une france à
plusieurs vitesses qui est en train
d'émerger et vous voyez bien que la
france qu'on appelle la france
périphérique et une france qui
aujourd'hui souffrent de ceux de cette
perte je veux dire de politique publique
en matière d'aménagement du territoire
et ça je sais pas comment j'arrive et
chaque fois que je viens ici j'arrive à
la place et et je pense que la politique
d'aménagement du territoire doit
s'appuyer sur la politique culturelle et
notamment sur la politique du patrimoine
parce que la première pratiques
culturelles des français c'est le
patrimoine le patrimoine entendu pas
seulement comme les chapelles où les
églises romanes mais aussi comme les
anciennes friches industrielles mais
aussi comme les anciennes mines etc etc
comme quelque chose qui fait que cette
france qu'on imagine avoir tiré
d'affaires parce qu'après l'avoir
appelée la france d'en bas on appelait
la france profonde et maintenant on
l'appelle la france périphérique mais
cette france-là désir qu'on lui
manifeste qu'on la considère qu'on sait
ce qu'elle a représenté qu'on sait ce
qu'elle peut représenter et par
conséquent pour ça c'est la politique
culturelle et notamment celle du paris -
je le redirai la prochaine fois on
l'inviterait où la place est à chaque
fois w s'inquiète de l'aménagement du
territoire et par exemple du manque de
4g encore le dit je vous donne rendez
vous le 19 septembre il ya un rapport
qui était commandée par julien normandie
qui va être publiée sur ce qu'on appelle
le développement des tirs lieu sérieux
ses voeux aux français pour parler des
espaces de coworking
il faut savoir qu'il existe en france
des centaines de lieux de coworking ou
la 4g passe ou du moins il ya du haut
débit qui permet justement à des gens
qui ne sont pas dans leur entreprise
d'aller travailler soit parce qu'ils
sont indépendants soit parce qu'ils sont
en télétravail et qu'ils arrêtent de
travailler dans des conditions qui sont
tout à fait honorables et on n'imagine
pas vous parliez de développement des
lieux culturels et que l'aménagement du
territoire passera par le développement
culturel dans ces lieux là il y à des
espaces de travail mais il ya aussi du
développement
culturel qui permet de créer des espaces
des véritables espaces qui sont
combinées qui sont intelligents où on
travaille on réfléchit on se cultive
on fait du sport c'est un fertilisant
donc vont pas l'aimer mais en tout cas
il ya des initiatives qui existent qui
sont dans les banlieues ou qui sont dans
les espaces déconcentrés et c'est plutôt
une bonne chose et je pense que demain
le travail demain s'appuiera aussi sur
ces espaces là à ce propos on revient
vraiment sur l'aspect travail travail
laurent berger qui était donc l'invité
de rtl ce matin
parlez-lui de la souffrance au travail
je met en rapport avec les questions de
management c'est lorsqu'on a fait notre
enquête sur le parle on travaille là 45%
des personnes qui nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient des impacts physiques de leur
travail sur leur santé augmentation et
c'est un vrai sujet l'augmentation les
arrêts de travail
il est lié aussi à un vieillissement de
la population un recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sur la qualité de vie au
travail sur la façon dont les gens
vivent leur tige est entièrement raison
d'ailleurs et même la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn le dit sur la
l'augmentation des arrêts maladie qui
ont comme on connaît depuis trois quatre
ans alors qu'ils sont logiques quand y
ait de la croissance les gens sont plus
malades c'est un principe de base c'est
conjoncturel on le sait on l'a toujours
observé oui parce qu'il est lié aux
réformes des retraites qui ont repoussé
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce qui
fait que les gens vivent plus longtemps
mais vivent plus longtemps au travail et
donc forcément on est moins habile on
est moins mobile on est moins en forme
quand on à 61 ans 62 que quand on en a
58 et donc on est plus souvent travail
ça c'est la première application qui est
tout à fait pointer du doigt qui se voit
dans les statistiques de la cnam la
deuxième explication c'est le fameux
bord out et burn out et sa agnès buzyn
le reconnaît également en disant que la
démotivation le fait clairement au
travail
le fait que les process sont de plus en
plus compliqué avilissant et un an des
enfants utilisant et handicapant pour
les personnes jouent et provoque des
arrêts de travail à répétition
c'était passionnant je laisse le mot de
la fin joséphine qui était donc manager
et qui nous dit
nous donne sa définition du management
il faut de l'objectivité être juste et
réaliste et ne pas accepter
l'inacceptable
ça vous convient oui j'ai du sens il
faut donner du sens il faut que les gens
comprennent pourquoi ils travaillent
elon musk a quelques problèmes en ce
moment il est tyrannique
ces entreprises perdent de l'argent mais
tout le monde veut travailler avec lui
parce que quand il nous dit je vais
coloniser mars peut parfaitement être en
désaccord sur le projet mais il ya un
truc hein il ya un projet mêlant dégâts
coloniser mars c'est un projet et ça
c'est très important pour les gens qui
ont vu de ce qu'il a fait par le passé
en 10 il peut y arriver lui par contre
il faut se méfier en plus il est capable
via les dépressions épuisement il semble
aussi on aurait dit merci d'avoir
rétabli français on n'aura pas parler du
chômage de l'assurance chômage ce sera
sans doute pour une autre fois
intéressant que ce débat sur le
management soit menée le plus
complètement possible
merci beaucoup à tous merci à valentin
pilate qui nous a référé